what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so as I mentioned when we started
doing really everything after Sinestro
Corps war that there was something like
five or six different preludes to
blackest night because blackest night is
such a huge event it's like the war of
life so as black as night as bright as
day there's a lot of stuff that goes on
there but this is actually a pre mood to
rage of the Red Lanterns which is a pre
loo to blackest night so this is like a
prelude to a preview but it gets pretty
cool in terms of how all this unfolds
because what this does is this deals
with the early formation of the Red
Lantern Corps but it really also deals
with this coming together of the war of
light now the cool thing about this is
that this initially focuses on the
nature of individuals who are basically
becoming what are called alpha lanterns
and alpha lanterns are actually a pretty
cool concept and the reason why is
because these are basically policemen
for the green lantern themselves will
actually get into that here in a second
what we end up doing is we actually pick
up with Sinestro now for those of you
guys who were just now joining us
Sinestro Corps war was really like the
last big event that we did and that's
really the only thing you need to know
in order to be able to follow this bit
of a story here but what ended up
happening is that the former Green
Lantern Sinestro had basically long
since defected from the Green Lantern
Corps after basically being shunned
aside and then making himself a yellow
lantern only for us to find out that he
eventually came along and formed his own
Lantern Corps called the Sinestro Corps
now initially the arrival of the
Sinestro Corps came by way of these
small little things it would pop up here
and there wasn't any great big huge
event that just suddenly happened it was
just the small little tidbits these
small little teasers that would crop up
every once in a while suddenly a lantern
ring would appear before Bruce Wayne and
it would say Batman you have the ability
to instill great fear
welcome to the Sinestro Corps or
something along those lines but what
ended up happening is that with this
Sinestro Corps war while the Sinestro
Corps was defeated the overarching goal
of Sinestro was not to eliminate the
Green Lantern's in their entirety
although it would have been nice if he
had the goal was to arrange the nature
of the Green Lantern's so they no longer
serve their purpose anymore so for those
of you guys who are reading how Jordan
and the Green Lantern Corps in DC
rebirth or you were reading Green
Lantern's prior to DC rebirth then you
know the long game that Sinestro is
playing and really they kind of offer a
bit of a spoiler for what it is that
he's doing later on down the line at
least you know this
stuff that will cover hello in like six
or seven months it'll be a while before
we get there but the idea was that the
Green Lantern's always existed as a
peacekeeping force and so they didn't
really have the ability to kill people
they would simply just use the Rings to
take them prisoner and then whisk the
bad guys away that was the only role
they played but now the Green Lantern's
have the ability to use lethal force
there what this means is that people
will start to look at the Green
Lantern's in a different eye you'll
begin to look at them as killers and so
all Sinestro has to do is sit back and
let the court of public opinion play its
role and ultimately people will begin to
turn on the Green Lantern's that's
ultimately what ends up happening with
regards to Sinestro taking over the
universe really you know using the
Sinestro Corps as his own personal army
different things like that but again the
funny thing about this is this hits home
at the nature that Sinestro effectively
won that he won the Sinestro Corps war
sure he was taken prisoner most of his
guys were killed but at the end of the
day he won because the goal of Sinestro
was to spread fear and that's exactly
what he did he instilled fear in a
Lantern Corps that otherwise existed to
overcome fear and so it's this really
really good example of if you're trying
to conquer a country you don't invade
the country that's not what you do you
don't go into a country invaded and call
it a day what you do is you get the
government of that country to turn its
guns on its citizens and then eventually
it'll turn into an uprising a revolt and
when that country's at its weakest then
you conquer it that's exactly how
Sinestro plays this stuff out and so we
end up doing here is joining a handful
of different people who are basically
coping with the loss of different Green
Lantern's that had perished during the
Sinestro Corps war but one of the most
important characters here and really the
star of this particular story is a girl
named Lyra one of the members of the
lost lanterns now the reason why I say
lost lanterns if you're just now joining
us or if you've been watching this for a
little while
bear with me for a second for that for
the new folks back in 1993 when Hal
Jordan became a bad guy he was basically
possessed by the parallax entity which
is to say the entity that represents all
fear that exists in the universe the
result was that Hal Jordan became a bad
guy he laid waste to the entirety of the
Green Lantern Corps it was believed that
he had killed them all what we ended up
finding out is that some of the original
Green Lantern's that were believed to
have been killed by Hal Jordan actually
survived and they were being held
captive by cyborg
man and the Manhunters of course you'll
find all this stuff in our Green Lantern
playlist if you want to if you want to
get caught up but the idea here was that
these lanterns who were previously
believed to have been dead and then
discovered to have been alive are what I
refer to as the lost lanterns but the
thing that differentiates them from all
the other lanterns that are out there is
that while they are basically making
their return they're essentially
veterans they had been fighting his
green lanterns for quite some time
not only that they all Harbor just this
extreme hatred for Hal Jordan because
the last memory they have of him he
turned against them all and tried to
kill him but the character of Lyra is
one of the lost lanterns she's
experienced nothing but just trial and
torment one of the things they talk
about here in little walk is that her
father had basically committed suicide
and the result of this is that with her
father having been a renegade having
basically been a shunned Lantern lost
his honor Lyra was carrying this around
no matter where she went as a green
lantern no matter what she did people
always saw her as the daughter of a
shunned Lantern and so with that legacy
following her around combined with the
fact that she'd been betrayed by Hal
Jordan and then now lost one of her
fellow lost lanterns her life is
literally in turmoil and so what is it
happening here is that on the journey
back to the home planet of ki Han where
they're basically taking his body back
to his family
once the lost lanterns arrive they
basically end up finding out that every
single person had been killed now this
had been done by character named animus
ork
now the cool thing about this is that if
you are pretty new to Green Lantern Amon
Sora is the son of a dancer and having
Seward was the guy who crash-landed on
earth and basically told his ring find a
new host and his ring found Hal Jordan
and so because of this Amon saw always
believed but he should have been the
heir to his father's rank now when it
comes to the Green Lantern mythos that's
not unprecedented it's not like a man's
or just kind of came out of nowhere with
this belief system that's happened quite
a few times when it comes to different
different lanterns that are out there I
believe tomar ray was the father and
tomar two is the son but when it comes
to the different green lanterns that are
out there there are times where a Green
Lantern will perish in battle and then
their offspring will take up the mantle
and so again it's kind of a cool
scenario and a Mansoor believed that he
should have been in line for his
father's rent the result is that how
Jordan got it instead and Amon Sora had
been consistently plotting ways to
basically bring down Hal Jordan now all
this coincided with the emergence of the
son
and a masseur being given a ring for
what this did is it led to its most
logical conclusion when a man saw
basically is the one that killed the
entire family of ki Han and then Lyra in
her anger and her rage basically lashes
out and kills a man Seward now here's
the interesting thing about this with
the Sinestro Corps despite the fact that
they had these rings that allow them to
do all kinds of different things when it
comes to the different cores that exist
in the DC mythos they all exist to feed
off of emotion so the Green Lantern's
feed on willpower so long as there's
somebody out there who's willing to
stand up you know and say I'm not afraid
then there will be willpower in the
universe at the same time so long as
there's somebody there who says oh my
god I'm so scared that things might go
bad there will always be fear in the
universe as long as there's somebody
who's angry as long as there's somebody
who loves as long as there's life as
long as there's death those aspects of
the emotional spectrum will always exist
and the course will always be there and
so because of this Amon sort of believed
that he could basically turn himself
into a martyr that what he could do is
he could allow himself where he could go
through kill the family of ki Han and
then other members of the Sinestro Corps
would see how this impacted existing
Green Lantern's and in turn take up the
same task and literally just start
killing off families of Green Lantern's
who exist again sowing chaos reaping war
you know guerrilla warfare tactics
against a far more organized and
structured Lantern Court especially
considering that the Sinestro Corps does
not have their leader Sinestro because
he's currently held in prison and so
with the death of Amon sewer what
happens here is this ring basically just
takes off to seek out a viable host it
ends up attempting to bond itself to the
Scarecrow now the funny thing about this
is that this is actually a teaser of
things to come because the Scarecrow is
going to play a pretty cool role once we
start getting it like blackest night and
brightest day in different things like
that where the ring initially appears to
him with the intention of bonding itself
of course how Jordan and John Stewart
show up they basically save the day and
nothing happens you know that Scarecrow
doesn't end up getting a ring but what
this does is this leads into the trial
of Lyra when it came to the Sinestro
Corps war one of the major laws that was
basically implemented by the guardians
of the universe was that those
individuals who are members of the Green
Lantern Corps have authorization to use
lethal force against members of a
Sinestro Corps and that's literally the
argument that lyer uses she says who
cares
I killed him what he what matters is
that he was a villain you know he did
some terrible things he killed a family
of ki Han he deserved to die and so I
killed him now her argument is not
without merit let's say for example she
didn't kill a man sort and let's say
that a masseur was captured for his
crimes he was brought back to OA and
then he escaped well that would mean he
would go right back to doing what he was
doing before he would go right back to
killing people why sacrifice the lives
of others that's basically the argument
is being made you know from the Green
Lanterns when the guardians of the
universe is Hey look justice is the most
important thing and so yes this guy
killed children but he deserves a fair
trial just like everybody else no he
doesn't he gave up that right when he
murdered a family he sacrificed that
that's the choice that he made he looked
at the consequences of his own actions
and said if I commit this crime there is
a good chance somebody's going to come
and kill me and I don't care why give
that chance why go to a three-year-old
or four-year-old or an 80 year old woman
and say hey look yeah there's a chance
you're going to die and a masseur is
going to be the one to kill you and it's
such that's going to happen but do you
know it's just the price we pay when it
comes to justice I mean I don't know
what to tell you it doesn't work that
way that God made a choice he paid the
price and the result is that the Green
Lantern's effectively turn on Lyra now
what this also does is this brings in
something called the Alpha lanterns and
the reason for this is because the
actions of Lyra throw into sharp relief
that there are going to be Green
Lantern's out there who are going to
basically look at the rules as they
exist and then interpret them different
ways and that's the problem is that
these rules are not absolute these rules
are basically written away where anybody
can look at them you can show the rules
to five different people and give them
each a circumstance and they'll
interpret the rules and different ways
the law says lethal force can be used
against a member of the Sinestro Corps
it does not say lethal force can be used
but only if they're trying to attack you
it doesn't say that and so in truth she
has all legitimate means to make this
case what the guardians basically do is
that instead of coming along and saying
okay we are going to make a law and then
we're going to add stipulations to that
law for every conceivable circumstance
that could possibly exist what the end
up doing is they come along and they
create D alpha lanterns and the Alpha
lanterns serve the purpose of basically
being field police they're the ones that
show up if a green
Antron goes out and commits something
they shouldn't do but technically
speaking they fall within the confines
of the law the Alpha lanterns will
respond and the Alpha lanterns will
analyze the situation they'll be the
ones to basically decide whether this
Lantern was right or wrong
now the question has to be asked how
does this fix anything what's different
from the Alpha lanterns showing up and
saying yep they're right - just another
arbitrary Green Lantern showing up and
saying no they're wrong the reason why
this matters is because if you're new to
the whole Green Lantern mythos back when
the guardians of the universe first
tried to create order tried to instill
order across the universe they created
what we're called the man hunters and
the man hunters are basically these
robots that were tasked with the purpose
of keeping the universe safe the problem
with this is that the Manhunters
programming eventually went awry they
basically became bad guys it is sort of
cutting a swath through the universe
killing all different forms of life on
the name of order and justice and so
eventually the guardians of the universe
had to do away with the Manhunters and
in turn began creating the Green Lantern
Corps under the idea that Green
Lantern's would be able to use their own
experiences their own understanding of
right and wrong and then decide what
action needs to be taken all of which
was predicated on the fact that before
Sinestro Corps war Green Lantern's
couldn't kill and so the idea that Green
Lantern's can kill complicates
everything
and so what ends up happening here is
that where individuals are basically
chosen to become alpha lanterns and jon
stewart's one of them Jon Stewart
actually turns them down Jon Stewart
actually says no he doesn't want to be
any part of that and the reason why is
because the Guardians say the Alpha
lanterns will exist to basically serve
the purpose of enforcing the ten laws
that the guardians of the universe have
put into creation the problem with this
is that only two of those laws are known
and so those individuals who signed up
to become alpha lanterns don't know what
other laws they're going to be forced to
implement they could very well be forced
to implement laws that say it's illegal
to fly from one side of the universe to
the other on a Thursday we have no idea
what these laws are going to be I mean
it would be anything that ridiculous but
you guys understand what I'm saying
they're basically signing up to enforce
rules that they don't know anything
about what the Alpha lanterns do is
basically stand as this sort of
combination of machinery and biological
organisms they're effectively cyborgs or
at least they seem to be that way no
reason why this is so cool is because
Green Lantern's traditionally which is
to say how Jordan John Stuart kyle
rayner Guy Gardner
they have to charge their rings their
rings while we run low the reason why
this is important is because with the
Alpha lanterns they don't have that
problem the Alpha lanterns main line the
central power battery and so it's like
the difference between you having a
remote control that runs off batteries
and having a remote control that plugs
in from the wall at the end of the day
they do serve the same purpose but one
is not going to run out of power as long
as you have power going to your house
and so what ends up happening here is
that where Lyra just immediately loses
it when everybody basically says okay
look you know you are effectively guilty
we're going to hold you accountable for
your crimes the Alpha lanterns begin the
process of essentially arresting her but
in this particular circumstance the
Alpha lanterns begin to demonstrate this
sort of totalitarian position we're so
much like they just start executing or
at least they intend to execute Lyra on
the spot now this is important because
what this does is it sets the stage for
the possibility of the guardians of the
universe repeating their mistakes again
regarding to the universe have
consistently shown themselves to be
extremely intelligent and very capable
they're able to make mistakes just like
everybody else they can't see the future
they don't know everything about
everything and the awful lanterns are a
perfect example of that
creating a police force within the Green
Lantern's with virtually no oversight is
going to end in nothing good it's going
to cause all kinds of problems and so
what is it happening here is that what
the first law having already been
written what the Guardians do is they
come along and they basically write in
stone the second law and the second law
is that anybody who is an enemy of the
Green Lantern Corps will be met with
lethal force by the Green Lantern's now
this is important because when end up
happening is during Sinestro Corps the
Guardians of the Universe said lethal
force is authorized
against the Sinestro Corps that was it
it was only against the Sinestro Corps
now again this hits back home to the
conversation that Hal Jordan has with
Sinestro where Sinestro says I told you
I was right I told you that I won this
war because now that the Green Lantern's
can use lethal force against anybody
who's an enemy of the Green Lantern
where does that stop is an enemy of the
Green Lantern a person that's running
for political office that disagrees with
Green Lantern's is an enemy of the Green
Lantern's a person standing on a street
corner saying I don't believe the Green
Lantern's are right where do you draw
this line at what point do you say yes
this person is an enemy
they're not a mortal enemy they're not
going to actually do us any harm you
know this allows the stage to be set for
the Green Lantern's to be transformed
from a peacekeeping force into a
militaristic controlling force
effectively becoming exactly what
Sinestro wanted them to be where they
use fear and they use force to maintain
order across the universe as opposed to
allowing people to basically live their
own lives and so what ends up happening
here is to basically pick up with
library as she's being transported back
to where I plan it because again what a
person is found guilty of a crime like
this in the Green Lanterns they're
basically just kicked out that's really
all it is it's just you're banned from
the Green Lantern Corps and you're sent
back home now for a lot of people this
is a big deal because remember when a
person is given a Green Lantern ring a
massive amount of power comes with that
the Green Lantern ring becomes as much
their identity as it becomes a source of
power in this instance that was the only
way for Lyra to at least as far as she
perceived it to regain the honor lost by
her father but being kicked out of the
Green Lantern means she's now just the
daughter of a father who was shamed and
who was shunned for his actions as a
renegade Lantern and basically just
kicked out of the court and so because
of this in this moment when she just
swears absolute vengeance against you
know against anybody you know that
that's considered to be an enemy of her
or at least all the other members of the
Sinestro Corps she suddenly met with the
arrival of a Red Lantern ring and this
marks chronologically the first time in
DC Comics that the Red Lanterns actually
make their appearance but the secret
origin of Hal Jordan that we did earlier
and when we started the whole Green
Lantern thing technically speaking that
happens after this but the cool thing
about this is that this is the first
introduction of the Red Lanterns and the
DC the first time that we actually see a
Lantern Corps that's predicated on
absolute pure and unadulterated rage but
when happening said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]